j'ouvre tout de suite notre second débat
vous le savez on le choisit le plus
souvent possible volontairement décalé
de l'actualité du jour il est consacré
ce soir à la santé des femmes notre
médecine est-elle sexiste c'est la
question que je vais poser à mes invités
dans un instant mais d'abord un premier
constat les maladies cardiovasculaires
et les représentent la première cause de
mortalité chez les femmes mais leur
symptômes sont différents de ceux des
hommes ce qui conduit à des erreurs de
diagnostic reportage à Soissons dans
l'Aisne Flora sauvage est partie à la
rencontre de Virginie victime d'un
infarctus à 42 ans je m'appelle Virginie
j'ai 45 ans et il y a deux ans j'ai fait
un infarctus et les signes ne m'ont pas
affolés tout de suite je suis revenue
dans ma voiture ma fille était avec moi
et c'est ma fille qui m'a dit maman moi
je Tu m'inquiète je j'aimerais bien que
tu ailles à l'hôpital donc j'étais pas
forcément trop d'accord pour y aller du
coup elle a assisté un peu
et je suis allée aux urgences de
l'hôpital de Soissons à l'image de
Virginie les femmes ont tendance à
minimiser leurs symptômes et ces
symptômes s'expriment parfois
différemment chez la gente féminine les
maladies cardiovasculaires représentent
la première cause de mortalité devant le
cancer du sein quand je suis arrivé à
l'hôpital j'étais pas non plus plus
inquiète que ça et je n'aurais pas pensé
que ça pouvait être ça j'ai senti voilà
une douleur quelque chose de très très
supportable et pas comme ce qu'on peut
imaginer
dans l'inconscient collectif comme la
douleur de l'infarctus du tout du tout
je suis allée me coucher comme
d'habitude j'ai bien dormi je me suis
levé pour m'occuper de mes enfants de
mon mari
et puis là je me suis j'étais très
essoufflée très essoufflé et très très
fatigué à l'hôpital les médecins vont
lui poser deux stent pour éviter une
nouvelle obstruction de l'artère depuis
Virginie garde une petite insuffisance
cardiaque qui induit des traitements
quotidiens c'est une période où j'étais
reparti dans des études j'étais éloignée
de mes enfants du coup quand même quasi
toute la semaine
il fallait gérer ça gérer du coup le
quotidien un peu moins mais il y avait
le manque de ma vie de famille forcément
et puis le fait de reprendre des études
après 40 ans bon ben c'est pas la même
chose que quand on en avait il faut pas
se voiler la face non plus donc oui
c'est des charges de stress qui sont
importantes mais j'imaginais pas qu'à 42
ans en étant une femme on pouvait
avoir ce type de pathologie si les
femmes sont sous représentées dans la
recherche médicale elle souffre aussi de
retard de diagnostic qui peuvent leur
être fatale chaque jour en France 200
femmes meurent d'une maladie
cardiovasculaires il y a très peu
d'études avec une réelle parité
homme-femme ce qui fait que l'on a pour
certaines recherches des conclusions qui
s'appliquent aux femmes
alors que elle représente 10 à 15 % de
l'effectif étudié à cela s'ajoute la
méconnaissance des particularités
féminines par le corps médical cette
spécificité des maladies
cardiovasculaires chez les femmes
n'étaient pas enseignées jusque il y a
encore très peu de temps et cela
entraîne effectivement une
sous-estimation du risque vasculaire
chez les femmes un homme jeune qui va
arriver avec une douleur thoracique on
pensera d'abord effectivement une
pathologie cardiovasculaire
chez une femme on pensera plus un effet
de stress de charge psychosocial
important et qui va conduire soit un
mauvais diagnostic soit un diagnostic
retardé et les chiffres parlent pour
eux-mêmes une une victime d'un arrêt
cardiaque à deux fois moins de chance
d'y survivre qu'un homme
sa médecine est-elle sexiste c'est le
thème de notre débat avec Catherine
Vidal bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes membre
du comité d'éthique de l'Inserm et du
Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes auteur de ce livre
prendre en compte le sexe et le genre
pour mieux soigner un enjeu de santé
publique ce n'est pas un rapport merci
il faut de la précision on va essayer
d'en avoir Caroline de pauvre bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes sociologue
chercheuse associés au centre lillois
d'études et de recherche sociologique et
économique et votre livre cette fois-ci
on est bon c'est la santé des femmes un
guide pour comprendre et les enjeux et
agir aux éditions Mango et Laurence
Cohen bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
c'est la crise communiste du
Val-de-Marne vice-président de la
délégation au droit des femmes qui a
entamé c'était à la mi-novembre ces
travaux sur ce thème justement de la
santé des femmes et notamment la santé
au travail on y viendra ce sera l'un des
chapitres de notre débat évidemment
peut-être une réaction à notre reportage
pour pour commencer Catherine Vidal de
100 femmes meurent chaque jour de
maladie cardiovasculaire est-ce que
c'est
notamment lié le reportage il faisait
aussi de la pédagogie à la
méconnaissance des symptômes pas
vraiment pas vraiment disons que il y a
de nombreux facteurs qui font que dans
une réalité
les femmes vont tarder à appeler les
urgences en cas de symptômes en cas de
problème et que quand elles arrivent à
l'hôpital leur prise en charge va être
plus tardive que celle des hommes un
symptôme égal donc pour essayer de
comprendre cette situation
il faut réfléchir non seulement aux
aspects qui pourraient être aux aspects
concernés les aspects biologiques liés à
l'expression de certains symptômes qui
pourraient être présents ou pas chez les
femmes différemment des hommes mais ce
n'est pas le facteur principal le
facteur principal c'est le fait qu'il
existe toujours dans le corps médical et
également dans le grand public des
stéréotype sur les maladies masculines
ou féminines et ces stéréotypes vont
faire justement que on va se dire pour
un infarctus ça c'est une maladie
d'hommes typique un don stressé au
travail c'est pas une maladie de femme
inversement on va dire
l'ostéoporose c'est une maladie de femme
ménopausées c'est pas une maladie
d'homme or c'est faux c'est à dire que
tous ces stéréotypes qui voudraient
mettre les hommes et les femmes dans des
cases en fait maintenant avec toutes les
recherches scientifiques qu'on a pu
faire dans le domaine et c'est ce que
j'ai pu renseigner dans le rapport que
j'ai fait pour le Haut Conseil à
l'égalité toutes les études au niveau
international je parle des études
scientifiques avec des des sources
extrêmement rigoureuses et robustes
monstre à quel point les facteurs
socioculturels et économiques vont être
responsables
d'inégalités de santé entre les femmes
et les hommes dans la prise en charge
médicale et dans l'accès je comprends
que les raisons biologiques mais
Caroline de Pau il y a quand même et
c'est pour moi d'ailleurs c'est c'est
sociologique ou culturelle je ne sais
pas mais quand on effectivement quand on
dit infarctus investi on pense à des
symptômes qui sont plutôt des symptômes
masculins dans la connaissance commune
ou quoi il y a une grande campagne d'une
assignation en ce moment où on voit un
docteur un peu d'honneur qui fait
infarctus dans son cabinet et
heureusement il y a une formation qui a
été financée donc il est sauvé par une
de ses patientes que les gestes qui
sauvent
on est dans le stéréotype du de l'homme
travailleur d'une cinquantaine d'années
qu'un peu voilà qui profite un petit peu
et qui fait son infarctus c'est ce qui
fait qu'en effet une femme qui va venir
avec pour certaines d'entre elles les
symptômes qui sont moins typiques en
plus elle peut avoir les symptômes
classiques les mêmes que ceux des hommes
et les symptômes atypiques quand elle va
arriver si les soignants n'ont pas
travaillé un peu sur leur propre
stéréotypes et leurs images on va voir
tendance à dire c'est une mère de
famille elle a un travail important elle
a une charge mentale qui est importante
du coup la dame en témoignait bien
disait j'ai senti une grande fatigue euh
bah on lui dit bah madame c'est
psychologique allez vous reposer aller
voir un psychologue et puis bah en fait
elle est en train de faire un factus le
temps qu'on perd voilà la perte de
chance c'est très important et on la
retrouve aussi à la récidive
c'est-à-dire qu'une fois que vous avez
fait un infarctus c'est déjà pas sympa
mais en plus normalement vous êtes fille
particulièrement parce que vous êtes à
risque sur les la période suivante on
retrouve cette même perte de chance sur
la période suivante on va à nouveau
avoir tendance à minimiser ce qui va
revenir et avoir attends sa minimiser
quand elles vont revenir pour les pour
des suspicions de de récidive Laurence
Cohen la santé des femmes est-ce que
c'est pas finalement alors ça peut être
c'est peut-être en train de changer mais
sur d'angle mort de de des politiques de
santé publique depuis des décennies et
pourquoi même presque dire plus quoi
alors ce qui ce qui a été souligné c'est
qu'effectivement les choses quand même
évoluent échangent et qui a une prise de
conscience qu'il y a effectivement des
travaux importants au niveau
international et que petit à petit il y
a d'ailleurs un certain nombre de de
pays qui sont depuis longtemps sur sur
ces questions je pense au pays de
du Nord aux États-Unis au Canada
on est plutôt en retard et c'est pour ça
qu'elle a délégation au droit des femmes
on a décidé de travailler sur ce sujet
plus spécifiquement aussi sur la santé
des femmes au travail mais on voit bien
on a commencé les auditions et nous
allons rendre un rapport en mai juin
c'est comme toujours au niveau de la
délégation au droit des femmes des
participations de chaque groupe
politique au Sénat donc c'est une grande
richesse on travaille ensemble et on
arrive à produire donc non seulement des
constats qui sont importants parce que
ce sont des rapports parlementaires mais
aussi des recommandations et on s'appuie
évidemment sur les acteurs et les
actrices qui ont déjà un bagage et qui
nous aident par leur éclairage dans ce
dans ce débat sur la question de la
santé au travail je voudrais rester
encore un tout petit peu sur le la
question des des AVC avec ce cette
campagne d’information qui a été lancée
en l'occurrence par un assureur on voit
ce film il durant une cinquantaine de
secondes il est il est très intéressant
regardez
[Musique]
qu'est-ce qui se passe
oui je vais la chercher à l'école il y a
pas de souci
d'accord mon cœur je m'en occupe mon
cœur je sais pas mal aux dents
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va aller mon cœur
[Musique]
81 % des femmes font passer la santé de
leurs proches avant la leur moi c'est ce
chiffre qui qui me frappe dans ce dans
ce dans ce film dans ce clip Catherine
Vidal ça rejoint ce que vous ditiez tout
à l'heure c'est à dire que les
inégalités de santé elles sont d'abord
sociétales culturelle économique on en
parlera évidemment un peu plus tard
c'est ça le plus important oui il est
important dans ces questions de faire la
distinction entre différences de santé
qui sont liées qui sont liées à des
facteurs biologiques au niveau génétique
hormonale des organes reproducteurs bon
ça se évidemment c'est les différences
de santé entre les femmes et les hommes
et il y a la notion d'inégalité de santé
dans les inégalités de santé c'est là
qu'interviennent les facteurs sociaux
culturels et économiques pour lesquelles
la notion de genre joue un rôle
prépondérant la notion de genre veut
dire d'une part tous les stéréotypes
liés aux maladies soi-disant purement
masculines ou purement féminine mais il
y a aussi la réalité de la vie sociale
et économique et en particulier les
situations de précarité économique dont
les femmes sont les premières victimes
ça va entraîner un renoncement aux soins
et une mauvaise hygiène de vie
dramatique je reprends notre notre titre
est-ce que notre médecine est sexiste
est-ce que vous employez ce terme nous
on peut pas parler de médecine sexiste
c'est pas plus la médecine n'est pas
plus sexiste que n'importe quel domaine
qu'on peut croiser dans le champ social
c'est-à-dire que on a une longue
histoire derrière nous une longue
histoire qui s'appelle la domination
masculine qui fait que dans
la médecine dans la répartition des
rôles sociaux
quels sont les places occupées par les
et par les hommes tout au cours de
l'histoire on sait bien que ce n'est que
récemment on a pu avoir des lois qui
permettent d'espérer un peu plus
d'égalité dans la répartition des tâches
entre les femmes et les hommes dans la
société allez on va parler de la santé
au travail je propose à Quentin calmer
de nous rejoindre rebonsoir puisqu'on
l'a dit la délégation droit des femmes
s'intéresse spécifiquement ici au Sénat
à la santé des femmes au travail oui
c'est ça en fait le chant des des
recherches a été un peu spécifié entre
le début et maintenant vous allez
vraiment vous intéresser à la suite des
femmes au travail on l'a compris dans ce
cas nous serez l'une des quatre corps
auteurs de cette mission au Sénat alors
déjà dans les auditions qui ont lieu
depuis le mois de novembre on voit se
dégager un principal constat la
représentation de la pénibilité elle se
fait aux dépens des femmes il existe
bien un stéréotype des métiers fatigants
difficiles et il est quasi
systématiquement associé à un métier
masculin or les femmes c'est pas la
peine de le répéter mais quand même ça
fait du bien de le dire elles font de
nombreux métiers pénibles répétitifs
avec des positions douloureuses par
exemple mais historiquement ces
difficultés cette souffrance au travail
elle est moins bien prise en compte
écoutez Muriel salle qui est historienne
et qui est donc intervenue auprès de la
délégation droit des femmes du sein en
écoutant un extrait
on mesure bien mal la pénibilité des
emplois que les femmes occupent et pour
quelle raison et bien parce que il
existe dans notre pays des emplois dit
féminins donc considéré qu'un travail
requiert des qualités pour être fait
plutôt que des compétences va se référer
c'est référé à l'inné plutôt qu'à laquis
et ça empêche de prendre la mesure tant
du niveau de qualification qui est
requis que du niveau de pénibilité qui
est associé au travail et ça c'est
effectivement des mécanismes
intellectuels qui sont importants il y a
ainsi une sous-estimation de la
pénibilité du travail des femmes
également moins de programmes de
prévention voire aucun Caroline de Pau
vous parlez de ces femmes de ménage
exposées à des produits cancérigènes
mais sans que cela fasse l'objet
d'études contrairement par exemple au
BTP et vous le saluez ou de telles
études ont lieu mais pour les hommes
merci beaucoup Quentin effectivement
Caroline de Pau ce qu'on peut dire il
faut le rappeler plus emploi sont
précaires plus les femmes sont propose
oui c'est malheureusement mécanique
c'est-à-dire que quand on regarde les
chiffres objectivement
les femmes en précarité économique elles
vont être plus victimes du temps partiel
du temps partiel subit pas choisi sur
les bas salaires sur les métiers qui
sont notamment liés à des discontinues
et qui les exposent alors est-ce qu'on
peut voir quels sont les conséquences en
matière de santé ou est-ce qu'on manque
d'études qui permettent de le de le dire
finalement oui parce que autant sur la
recherche médicale il y a eu des gros
progrès de fait et les femmes sont dans
les essais thérapeutiques quasiment à
part égale
contre le même Vidal mais dans ce n'est
pas du tout dans la même chose dans le
secteur du travail dans la santé travail
les études sont encore majoritairement
fait auprès d'hommes sur des secteurs
d'hommes et donc on peine à avoir les
mêmes les données les chiffres et en
termes d'impact résultats vous vous
pouvez pas mener de politique de
prévention si vous n'allez pas chercher
les données pour avoir des résultats
Laurence Cohen ça sera l'un des
objectifs de de cette mission
d'information
bien sûr et dans cette mission en
informations donc nous sommes quatre
co-rapporteurs et je veux citer mes
collègues quand même Annick jacquemais
Marie-Pierre Richer Laurence Rossignol
et effectivement nous allons tout comme
pardon mais sur ce plateau il y a aussi
trois affectés
de l'ensemble de la société bien
évidemment au niveau de la délégation
droit des femmes il y a des hommes et il
y a des femmes après il y a un intérêt
particulier pour tel ou tel sujet et
puis il y a aussi les groupes qui
présentent des des candidatures donc
c'est ce qui est mélangé mais il faut
aussi et moi avant de répondre
précisément à votre question je pense
qu'on ne peut pas extraire la santé la
médecine de la société dans laquelle on
se trouve et du rôle un parti aux femmes
et aux hommes aujourd'hui même sur la
petite pub là et alerte sur à mon coeur
je prends soin de toi etc on voit bien
quand même que l'éducation
des enfants etc c'est encore
majoritairement les femmes qui le font
faire les les accompagnements etc c'est
une majorité de femmes enfin on peut le
voir et on va voir que dans tout dans
tous les secteurs je veux dire que c'est
comme ça et au niveau au niveau du
travail moi je suis très frappé parce
que je suis aussi Vice-Présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales et les
maladies professionnelles par exemple
sont totalement sous-estimés au niveau
des femmes qui exercent le métier
d'accompagnement à la personne or les
taux d'accident du travail sont
équivalents à ceux qu'on trouve au
niveau du bâtiment et tous les hommes
s'en moquent moi je mets les pieds dans
le plat parce que vous nous dites
effectivement on est céléritage de de
alors de domination masculine donc voilà
on est finalement le le produit de cette
domination
longue donc est-ce que aujourd'hui
encore il y a pas un manque d'hommes
investi dans ces questions c'est pas
enfin moi je dirais pas je ne dirais pas
aussi brutalement que les hommes s'en
moquent je ne moi j'aime bien mettre les
pieds dans ce plat mais au moins aussi
moi aussi au Sénat j'ai pas de problème
mais je ne dirais pas ça parce que je je
pense que c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué c'est à dire que c'est
effectivement l'héritage d'une société
patriarcale et on est toujours dans
cette société patriarcale parce que il
faut pas dire que tout a été réglé donc
il y a ça à voir avec ses lunettes là
mais en même temps également c'est que
c'est une sous-estimation de de des
tâches que font les femmes et de la
pénibilité au travail c'est-à-dire vous
avez parlé de gestes répétitif je pense
aux caissières par exemple tous les
troubles musculo-squelettiques sont
complètement
sous-estimés au niveau des femmes on ne
prend pas en compte que quand une femme
par exemple une aide à domicile
s'occupe d'une personne
âgée elle est obligée de soulever des
poids extrêmement importants et alors on
me dit oui il y a des technicités qui
font que elles vont avoir des des
possibilités d'être oui elles l'ont
quand elles sont parfois et pas dans
tous les dans tous les établissement
elles vont avoir ces facilitations mais
quand elles sont à domicile elles n'ont
pas et elles sont seules face aux
patients ou à la patiente donc il y a
quand même ça aussi je pense apprendre à
prendre en compte et puis la dernière
chose si je peux me permettre là je suis
parti ça y est mais je vais m'arrêter
mais mais je pense aussi que dans les
métiers que je cite accompagnement à la
personne aide à domicile etc on
considère que bien sûr c'est un métier
mais quand même il y a pas besoin de
beaucoup de qualification parce que les
femmes sont naturellement patientes et
elles occupent naturellement des enfants
de l'éducation et de l'accompagnement à
la personne donc ça joue aussi pour
reconnaître ce qu'elles font réellement
je suis frappé parce que vous dites sur
les troubles musculaires squelettiques
qui ne sont pas reconnus pour les
caissières parce que ce sont des femmes
voulaient dire que si c'était des
caissiers enfin ou quand c'est des
questions quand les sous-estime pas et
quand c'est les femmes se sont estimé
moi je pensais que pour le coup c'est un
truc qui avait été documenté et
et renseigné non c'est la reconnaissance
en tant que maladie professionnelle dans
les grilles
de conscience qui a commencé mais dans
la réalité des démarches qu'une femme
doit faire auprès de son employeur pour
que ces trous musculo-squelettiques les
risques psychosociaux également puissent
être officiellement reconnu comme
maladie professionnelle là c'est des
démarches extrêmement longues et
extrêmement difficiles par rapport du
fait que ces catégories professionnelles
parce que c'est catégorie
professionnelle voilà elles ne sont pas
dans les grilles classiques des maladies
professionnelles et je voudrais quand
même ajouter un point très important
dans la recherche justement une équipe
de l'Inserm a montré récemment que le
travail de nuit augmente de 26%, les
risques de cancer du sein
donc vous voyez c'est des choses aussi
qui sont tangibles il y a non seulement
l'aspect des conditions de travail sur
lesquels il faut être extrêmement
vigilant mais il y a des recherches qui
sont faites justement également
concernant le dépistage du cancer du
poumon dans des circonstances de
maladies professionnelles là il y a
également des lacunes énormes si on
pense
aux métiers de nettoyage avec tous ces
agents cancérogènes dans tous les
produits et autres il y a vraiment des
lacunes dans la reconnaissance de ces
maladies sur les lieux de travail alors
il y a un paradoxe quand même Caroline
depot c'est autour de l'espérance de vie
l'espérance de vie des femmes est
supérieure à celle des hommes l'ongle
les derniers chiffres de 2019
85,6 ans pour les femmes 79,7 pour les
hommes c'est un chiffre en trompe l'oeil
comment comment vous expliquer ce qui
nous peut apparaître à première vue
comme un paradoxe oui c'est exactement
ça au début on se dit pourquoi on
s'occupe de la santé des femmes
finalement elles veulent toutes plus
vieille que les hommes
des hommes et la santé des femmes c'est
que finalement après quand on regarde
derrière les chiffres et derrière la
statistiques globale et qu'on regarde
notamment l'espérance de vie en bonne
santé bah là pour le coup la tendance
n'est plus la même et finalement elles
ont à peu près la même que celle des
hommes elle vit juste plus longtemps
mais en moins bonne santé donc ça vaut
le coup de vive plus longtemps si on vit
dans un état dégradé moi je sais pas
vous moi je fais le choix que non en
fait donc c'est en fait c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt et après quand on
regarde finalement elles sont en plus
mauvaise condition de vie bien avant les
hommes leurs conditions de vie la charge
mentale qui est avec leurs conditions de
vie font qu'elles sont elles sont
dégradées bien plus plutôt que celle des
hommes et pour revenir juste sur le
est-ce que c'est une affaire d'homme ou
une affaire de femme de toute façon vous
entendez parce que moi mon champ de
recherche c'est pas la santé des femmes
c'est les inégalités sociales de santé
et pour vous donner moi je suis effaré
de voir qu'en effet depuis que on
travaille sur la santé des femmes je ne
traite qu'avec des femmes j'adore les
femmes je trouve sympa on est toutes
mobilisé on travaille bien mais quand je
travaille avec autour du handicap autour
d'autres j'ai pas que des personnes
handicapé en face de moi pourquoi pour
les femmes ce serait une affaire de
femmes en fait c'est donc c'est quoi
c'est une forme de désintérêt des hommes
en effet
aussi sur une mesure cosmétique de dire
on va leur faire plaisir on va s'occuper
des femmes on va le mettre sur le devant
de la scène et on a peut-être pas encore
décidé de complètement bouger le système
parce que s'occuper de la santé des
femmes c'est s'occuper du système dans
son ensemble et donc ça veut dire
comment on s'occupe de l'équité et pas
de l'égalité parce que les hommes ils
sont aussi victimes de de discrimination
et que aussi à leur stéréotypes aussi et
après il faut aussi penser à ceux qui
sont pour le coup dans transgenre et sur
sur d'autres identiques qui peuvent leur
poser aussi des soucis parce qu'au
niveau des statistiques eux ils sont
complètement absents pour pour donner un
peu matière à notre à notre débat il
faut quand même aussi comprendre par
exemple
quand les femmes se battent pour
l'amélioration de leurs conditions de
travail en fait elle se battent pour
l'ensemble
des travailleurs et des travailleurs je
vais donner un exemple très précis les
facteurs à l'époque les les facteurs
avaient donc des musettes qui étaient
extrêmement lourdes et c'était aussi une
enfin quand même l'illustration d'une
virilité l'homme fort c'est celui qui
porte et donc voilà sauf que les
conséquences pour les hommes étaient que
il y avait des conséquences par rapport
au dos par rapport au squelette et
cetera et cetera mais ils allaient pas
revendiquer que les musées étaient trop
loin à partir du moment où les femmes
sont entrées dans dans cette profession
et qu'elles ont revendiqué effectivement
le fait d'avoir des musettes moins
lourdes ou éventuellement d'avoir des
chariots etc ça n'a pas été seulement
pour elle ça a été pour l'ensemble des
des facteurs et on a vu une amélioration
pour tout le monde donc cette réflexion
elle profite pas seulement aux femmes
elles profitent à l'ensemble à
l'ensemble de la société et c'est pour
ça que c'est très très important et que
ça illustre en même temps la place que
on accorde aux femmes dans notre société
à tous les niveaux alors il y a
plusieurs chiffres que je voudrais vous
vous communiquer pour faire avancer
notre débat sur les effets indésirables
les femmes ont deux fois plus de risques
de développer des effets indésirables
aux médicaments que les hommes et alors
vous avez dit quelque chose tout à
l'heure sur les tests donc je vais vous
donner moi ce que j'ai trouvé dans le
rapport de la Haute Autorité de Santé en
2021 est-ce que c'est lié au test lors
des tests sur les animaux les
médicaments sont testés à 75% sur des
mâles et lors des essais cliniques les
médicaments sont testés à 67% sur des
hommes alors vous disiez que c'était
plus tout à fait vrai donc ce sont des
chiffres qui datent de plusieurs
dizaines d'années mais non là j'ai
rapport de la Autorité de Santé 2021
donc ils prennent des chiffres qui sont
vieux je dirais que il y a des grandes
chances bon ok donc ça donc ça ça c'est
amélioré ça c'est énormément amélioré en
ce qui concerne les essais cliniques
effectivement il y a une 20 20 30 ans
encore
les essais cliniques étaient menés
principalement sur des hommes parce que
à nouveau historiquement les normes
physiolog était celle du de la
physiologie des corps des hommes et
alors que les femmes étaient considérées
comme des êtres toujours un petit peu
souffreteux avec leurs problèmes
d'hormones avec cette fragilité physique
également fragilité morale et donc les
les critères de de la médecine était
basée les normes étaient basées sur le
corps des hommes bon ça a beaucoup
évolué évidemment et quand on prend
maintenant la réalité des chiffres qui
sont publiés par l'Organisation Mondiale
de la Santé par le Naiche qui est
l'équivalent de l'Inserm chez nous bon
ces chiffres il y a un registre
international de l'ensemble des essais
cliniques qui sont faits partout dans le
monde où il est absolument obligatoire
de de déclarer tous les essais cliniques
qui sont faits on est à 55 ans à peu
près quand on regarde les chiffres par
exemple entre 2008 et 2018 8 il y avait
50% ou plus de femmes inclus dans les
essais cliniques toutes pathologies
confondues alors selon les années ça
peut changer parce que si une année on a
une piste particulière sur comment
améliorer la
cancer la prostate ou des choses comme
ça il y aura plus de ces cliniques sur
les hommes et inversement pour les
femmes on peut avoir des posologies ou
des pharmacopées qui vont être liés au
sexe et non plus la taille du haut-poit
comme celle-ci je vais vous donner la
parole du juste là-dessus mais c'est
parfait Mathieu parce que vous m'offrez
la transition pour écouter Geneviève
courant ancienne membre du Haut Conseil
à l'égalité elle était dans une
interview à l'INSERM justement sur cette
question des médicaments des posologies
elle prend l'exemple du doliprane
pour tout adulte quel qu'il soit la
posologie est la même vous pouvez pour
le doliprane 1000 prendre 4 comprimés
par jour très bien quatre comprimés par
jour ça me concerne un mètre 60 54 kg
mais ça concerne aussi mon petit-fils 16
ans à mettre 95 70 kg quand je le
regarde que je le regarde je me dis que
les médicaments ingérés ils doivent pas
faire le même trajet ça doit pas être
tout à fait le même chose qui se passe
non seulement pour des questions de
taille de poids mais aussi de sexe la
répartition entre les muscles le
squelette
les hormones par exemple
n'est évidemment pas la même alors
Catherine Vidal donc vous nous dites les
tests ça c'est amélioré mais est-ce que
les essais cliniques pardon mais est-ce
que sur effectivement sur la posologie
finalement l'adaptation des médicaments
ça suit alors disons que sur le plan de
la pharmacologie enfin les médecins sont
suffisamment bien formés pour
savoir que selon la masse corporelle
selon l'âge et bien les doses doivent
être ajustées enfin c'est une évidence
sur l'exemple du doliprane c'est de
l'automédication on va chercher tout
seul etc
encore une fois c'est un individu qui
fait 50 kg
mais
je vais vous donner un exemple pressant
de trois personnes qui qui avait des
âges des poids des sexes différents qui
ont fait exactement la même posologie à
base de doliprane
par jour
bien sûr qu'il y a un souci
d'information mais ça c'est on est dans
un cas de l'automédication quand un
professionnel de santé fait c'est
prescriptions c'est quelqu'un qui a un
bagage qui a fait de des études et qui
sait très bien comment ajuster les doses
enfin c'est vraiment le baba de la
médecine on va parler maintenant de
d'endométriose puisque dans ces
inégalités de santé il y a aussi la
question des maladies spécifiquement
féminines alors je propose un témoignage
sur ce thème recueilli par nos
partenaires de loopsiders comédienne et
réalisatrice Lola B6 qui comme des
dizaines et encore je minimise un de
milliers d'autres femmes a été baladé
d'un médecin à l'autre faute de
diagnostics le plus c'est le bas du dos
quasiment
[Musique]
spécialiste de l'endométriose qui est
très rare en fait donc il m'a fallu six
mois pour avoir un rendez-vous et lui en
une minute même pas il m'a dit bah oui
oui c'est évidemment c'est devant de Me
triosité c'est un gynécologue qui m'a
prescrit la plus en continu parce qu'en
fait à ce jour c'est le traitement le
plus efficace dans le sens où ça stoppe
les règles et donc ça stoppe le
développement de la maladie
carnine de Pau je sais pas si vous avez
vu les titres de l'émission c'était il y
a un peu plus d'une heure mais on avait
donné la parole à une chantilly qui
s'appelle Imany qui qui avait participé
à une marche pour voilà et qui dit mais
très beau poème sur leur
maladie d'hommes ça fait bien longtemps
que les chercheurs auraient trouvé ou en
tout cas progresser vous êtes d'accord
avec ça je suis complètement d'accord
avec ça il y avait je pense que pareil
pour l'obésité je pense que ça touchait
un peu plus violemment socialement les
hommes on travaillerait beaucoup plus
aussi sur les conséquences de l'obésité
mais
parenthèse fermée mais sur
l'endométriose c'est c'est un sujet
après il y a le plan national qui quand
même amène une prise de conscience assez
forte et on voit que les il y a un an
par le Président de la République c'est
ça qui fait que les lignes elles
commencent quand même à bouger donc on
voit que il y a une prise en compte de
la douleur parce que finalement le sujet
c'est aussi comment on prend la con de
la douleur et l'expression de la parole
des femmes et sur ce sujet là en fait et
et l'errance c'est un petit qu'elle est
là c'est qu'à un moment on finit par
trop dire c'est dans la tête et que
alors qu'elle a un des symptômes qui
sont pour le coup quand elle les Anne
les énoncent en effet ça fait pas trop
de doutes mais ça veut dire qu'il y a
encore des des professionnels de santé
qui doivent être formés sur ces sur
cette prise en compte là et qui est
encore une marge de progrès à faire sur
le sujet Laurence Cohen je vous donne la
parole oui moi
est-ce que ça me paraît aussi très
important c'est qu'on considère aussi
que les femmes sont plutôt
plutôtérantes on va dire à la à la
douleur ou à certaines douleurs moi
j'étais frappée c'était pas par rapport
à la santé mais c'était par rapport aux
tortures donc c'est affreux en disant
que finalement les femmes ayant accouché
ayant des douleurs etc à l'accouchement
finalement elle supportait plus donc
vous voyez là je prends à quelque chose
d'extrême ce sont des tortionnelles etc
mais je veux dire
pourquoi
qu'il y a des idées reçues qui sont
liées au stéréotypes de genre fille et
garçon et qui explique un certain nombre
de choses et puis il y a effectivement
les errances de diagnostics à
l'endométriose c'est frappant mais je
pense aussi qu'il y a quelque chose qui
se développe dans notre société et qui
change c'est que les femmes sont
aujourd'hui en mesure de prendre la
parole contre les violences les
violences sexistes sexuelles ce qu'on
devrait aussi en parler par rapport à
notre à notre sujet et que du coup la
parole se libérant elles expriment aussi
les choses et elle ne supporte pas quand
il y a justement exporte moins c'est
errances diagnostic etc parce que on
voit que cette progression de cette
jeune femme comédienne etc elle existe
aussi parce que il y a eu une évolution
au niveau au niveau de la société donc
ça me semble aussi très important il
faut toujours lier avec les mouvements
dans dans la société me semble-t-il
Catherine est-ce que c'est c'est
spécifiquement français selon dont on
parle là pas du tout pas seulement sur
l'endométriose mais ça existe absolument
dans tous les pays mais je voulais
revenir sur l'endométriose parce qu'il y
a deux aspects très importants
fait partie des premières causes d'arrêt
de travail
donc qu'est-ce que ça veut dire si on
veut faire progresser un peu la prise de
conscience il faut que les médecins du
travail et que aussi les employeurs
soient misent au courant de la réalité
de cette pathologie or la médecine du
travail comme on le sait et là c'est une
discipline sinistrée une autre
discipline sinistrée c'est la médecine
scolaire parce que c'est à l'école les
infirmières souvent c'est des femmes qui
vont avoir à faire aux adolescentes qui
peuvent souffrir d'endométriose donc là
aussi il y a un travail de formation qui
doit être extrêmement importante or ces
deux domaines là à l'heure actuelle sont
quasiment
inexistants et ont perdu de leur
importance dans la dans la réalité de la
vie dans l'éducation et dans la vie
professionnelle Mathieu vouliez nous
parler d'une personnalité qui devait
être un symbole de cette cause de la
santé des femmes au sein du gouvernement
oui parce que ça devait être symbole et
il s'agit d'un symbole aujourd'hui
controversé je voulais vous parler de la
secrétaire d'État au développement et la
francophonie chrysola zacharoku
chirurgienne et gynécologue spécialiste
de l'endométriose on en parlait elle
voulait d'ailleurs faire cette maladie
chronique une cause nationale et elle a
d'ailleurs convaincu Emmanuel Macron
d'en faire un enjeu de santé publique en
lui en mettant un rapport il y a un an
car cette citoyenne grecque qui a fait
ses études en Italie
c'était par ailleurs rapproché de la
sphère politique etc prochaine de la
République en marche dès 2017 et même
engagé en politique puisqu'elle a été
élue député européenne sur la liste
review en 2019 au cours de la pandémie
de covid le chef de l'État même poussé
ses partenaires européens pour qu'elles
deviennent
vice-présidente de Kovacs vous savez le
dispositif européen de répartition des
vaccins entre les pays riches et les et
les pays pour vous mais voilà donc ça va
être un très beau symbole nommé au
gouvernement mai dernier la secrétaire
d'État du faire face à deux accusations
de viol et une autre de violence par
personne chargée de mission de service
public dans le cadre de son activité de
gynécologue que lui reproche les
enseignants par une enquête est en cours
mais certaines se sont confiées à la
presse et reprochent la
chrysolazakropoulu des gestes brutaux et
non consentis lors des examens
gynécologiques quelle pratiquaient sur
ces patientes dans un communiqué publié
le 24 juin assure d'avoir jamais imposé
de moindre le moindre examen à aucune de
ses patientes sans leur consentement et
l'estime que ces accusations graves à
son compte portent sur des examens
cliniques médicaux réalisés afin
diagnostiquer soigner la maladie de ses
patients et que ces accusations sont
inacceptables et révoltantes il
n'empêche alors que le gouvernement
était empêtré à l'époque dans l'affaire
Damien Abad vous souvenez de cet
éphémère ministre des Solidarités accusé
lui d'agression sexuelle beaucoup ont
fait l'amalgame ce qui entre nous et
pour moi pose de vraies questions les
deux cas n'ont rien à voir non
absolument aucun dans un cas on parle
d'examen médicaux qui aurait été mal
vécu ou peut-être mal réalisé selon les
plaignantes en tout cas pour le moment
dans l'autre selon les accusatrices on
parle de tentative de viol et
d'agression sexuelle en fin de soirée
alors entendons-nous les violences
gynécologiques et obstétricales sont un
vrai sujet qui mérite d'être réglé et le
régler fera sans doute avancer et
accélérer l'accès aux soins à des femmes
et leur santé en général mais on peut se
poser deux questions est-ce que la
qualification de viol retenue par deux
des plaignantes contre crise de servir à
la cause et est-ce que ça convaincra la
justice qui va devoir trancher à la fois
sur la question de l'intentionnalité et
puis sur le fait de savoir si une
pénétration commise lors d'un examen
gynécologique peut-être considéré comme
une pénétration sexuelle voilà deux
questions qui sont vont être forcément
tranchées et qui posent des vraies
questions au juristes et des vraies
questions évidemment au médecin donc en
attendant crisola zakapulu elle n'a pas
connu le destin de Damien Abad elle est
restée au gouvernement et c'est une très
discrète secrétaire d'État au
développement et à la Francophonie et
Elisabeth borne elle a saisi en juillet
dernier le comité consultatif national
d'éthique sur la question du
consentement dans le cadre médical
est-ce que ce terme de viol je vais vous
poser la question un peu la même
question à toutes les trois vous
semblent adaptés pour qualifier
excellent gynécologique c'est est-ce que
c'est pas finalement une confusion et sa
desserte pas une vraie question qui est
la cause des violences gynécologie après
il y a une qualification juridique d'un
violent si on est classé un viol c'est
tout acte de pénétration commis par une
personne avec
donc il y a la question de l'intention
sexuelle oui mais il n'empêche que pour
la victime ça en état c'est-à-dire que
il y a eu une période où il y avait
quand même aussi des examens gynéco qui
étaient faits quand les femmes étaient
endormis sous prétexte de former de
former les soignants sans leur
consentement c'est un viol
réveillez-vous mettez vous à la place de
ces femmes qui se réveillent et quand
elles ont même pas été au courant
carrément on leur a fait un frottis
quand elles étaient endormie moi je
pense que ce soit fait à l'hôpital c'est
même parfois pire parce qu'elles sont
dans un endroit qui est censés être
sécurisé donc elles sont censées être
entourées de bienveillance et puis c'est
pas le cas donc il y a aussi cette
notion-là qu'il faut prendre en compte
moi je pense je peux pas commenter
puisque c'est une une affaire de justice
effectivement je soutiens un certain
nombre d'associations qui se battent
contre les violences
obstétricales et je pense que c'est
extrêmement important et là on est un
sujet ça peut être quand même perturbant
ou fusant l'esprit de même moi je suis
d'accord c'est tout acte de pénétration
qui a été commis
contre enfin contre le consentement où
en dehors du consentement de la personne
je pense que la notion
de consentement est une notion qui est
extrêmement importante qu'on est en
train de travailler c'est une bonne
chose et je pense que il faut pas
justement alors c'est dommage parce
qu'on arrive à la fin de notre débat et
et on aurait pu aussi aborder les
violences sexistes et sexuelles qui ont
lieu notamment sur le lieu de travail à
l'encontre des femmes et qui sont bien
souvent minimisés complètement avec un
déni très important et qui porte aussi
préjudice parce que ça porte atteinte
évidemment à l'intégrité des femmes et
ça a des conséquences sur l'absentéisme
sur un certain nombre de maladies qui
sont extrêmement aussi
importantes et qu'on ne prend pas
suffisamment en compte donc il y a
vraiment besoin de former moi je partage
complètement former les professionnels
de santé à tous les niveaux et puis de
voir que notre système de santé est en
crise et c'est inadmissible que ça soit
la santé scolaire ou que ce soit la
santé au travail et bien soit aussi
autant sinistré que ça parce que quels
sont les recours pour les femmes qui ont
besoin effectivement d'avoir un suivi un
accompagnement médical merci beaucoup
merci à toutes et à tous on a
malheureusement terminé le temps de ce
débat mais alors 10 secondes à peine je
vous laisse saluer la démarche du Haut
Conseil à l'égalité qui est le premier
en 2017 à avoir fait un rapport sur les
violences gynécologiques et
obstétricales merci beaucoup encore une
fois merci à toutes d'avoir participé et
à tous à ceux débat à demain pour une
fois que c'est dans ce sens là elle
devint pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public côté notre prochain rendez-vous
politique sur notre antenne le maire du
Mans ancien ministre Stéphane lefaune
invité Dorian Mancini ce sera demain
dans la matinale
[Musique]